you have no fight on the schedule at the
moment is that right no no fight on the
schedule but i've got my eyes set on the
december 10 card
it's got me excited to be honest i'm
being excited in a long time
but if you share
the octagon the same night as jon jones
you're gonna be excited later yeah dude
yeah john john sat in that same seat
while i was sitting in this seat uh john
jones for me used the gold
dude you gotta give it to him remember
watching that fight live when he got
dq'd i was just like whoa what's being
indeed for
with the elbow
that needs overtaking and just so he's
got i know on his record because he
he's the man john jones
he he's a he's a definitely
complex individual yeah he is
that's what i mean that's another thing
like obviously
people don't say this and not about him
but bloody was out partying
sniffing a week before title defenses
and then just landed in the octagon and
finishing people yeah
that's a gangster right there yeah
i couldn't have said it better myself
out of all the people we've hung out
with like dude i had the best time
hanging out at john jones's house for
the those couple days like dude he's
just so accommodating he's like a little
kid he's bringing out drones and like
dude here put this on you're like flying
a drone like he he was i miss
like hanging out with john jones
i'm looking forward to like being on the
same cards and that's something that
does excite me being on the same card as
jones yeah do you know who you you who
do you want to fight i don't give a [ __ ]
anybody said that like people ask me you
do you want to fight and sam i don't
need to say any any name yeah it's that
simple i don't need to mention anything
because people talk about me
like people are just mentioning me left
right and sends an interview like people
who aren't my weight
talking about me to slanger
seeing some [ __ ] saying oh i'll come
up to featherweight and fight him why
are we like why would i go down to
featherweight to fight from nowhere what
i mean yeah
unbelievable and i think
i don't know that i've ever heard a
fighter say like
at a public level i don't care who i
fight i just don't want to fight a
ranked opponent
like that you know there's no point yeah
i'm not in no rush yeah as i say there's
no point in
jumping right off me like hey i'm going
to fight him i'm going to fight him
lightweight it doesn't work like that
right other divisions you can't do it
lad because of the division town shark
tanks
but this division is a crazy shark tank
club as i was saying through the day it
should have a top 30 never mind the top
15 but the divisions can just about eat
out the top 15 and 15 to 10 of that snad
but
the top 15 of lightweight is
top top notch fighters
yeah
instead shark tank is a good way to put
it i think that clip was awesome but not
as awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what i've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions which is
out september 27th and if you pre-order
it right now
you can get the autographed copy so get
on it man pre-order my book it's not
going to waste your time because i'm
proven dude new york times bestseller my
first book's five star rated on amazon
and i have no doubt this one will be two
so get the autographed copy right now by
pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude